-We just played
a game with Dr. Phil
called "Two Truths and a Lie."
-Oh.
-And he's at good at finding --
-Yeah. Okay.
-He's the best.
So, I thought...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
Start working it now,
because he's already
in your head.
-Whatever, Dr. Phil.
I need to meet
the "Cash Me Ousside" girl
before we talk.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Y'all trying to fix her
with psychology.
She need a 2x4.
Howbow dah?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, her mama need a 2x4.
-Exactly.
All of them.
-Let's hear -- Let's --
-Okay.
-Think of a truth or a lie...
-...and have Dr. Phil --
He'll judge you on it
and see if you're telling
a truth or a lie.
-Oh, okay.
Um, I got chased through
a drive-through by a car.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
On a date.
-[ Clears throat ]
You got chased
through a drive-through
by a car on a date?
-On a date.
-What kind of drive-through?
-Uh, it was McDonald's.
-McDonald's?
Did you already have your food?
-No, I ordered the food.
-What did you order?
-A sundae with no nuts, 'cause
he wanted to hit me with his.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbal crashing ]
-Yeah.
[ Closing theme plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sorry to interrupt.
Where were we?
-Let me tell you --
This girl is telling the truth.
-Yes.
-Are you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, you got it from that?
He's that amazing.
You're that amazing.
My thanks to
Leslie Jones and Dr. Phil.
A date?
-Yeah.
-We'll be right back
with a performance
from Rick Ross
featuring Young Thug and Wale.